à la une de ce barisien nouvelles
révélations dans une affaire qui agite
le monde entier depuis plusieurs jours
il ya du nouveau dans la sphère faute
bas pour rappel tout commence lorsque
mathias pogba frère de paul pogba poste
cette vidéo mystérieuse
chose très importante
certains prétendent alors que
l'international français aurait fait
appel à un marabout pour ensorceler qui
la même map et d'après les dernières
révélations paul pogba aurait bien
consulter un marabout mais pas pour
jeter un sort aux joueurs du psg il
assure avoir versé de l'argent aux
marabouts pour une association
humanitaire qui aide les enfants
d'afrique la maire de bolbec bord et
quand elles étaient menacées à son
domicile et livré désormais sous
protection ce soir on revient sur les
toutes dernières révélations
battant 24 ans et en direct et
chérissait touche pas à mon poste
nouvelle lourde révélations dans la
sphère pop bas et vous allez voir on va
voir la réaction de quillanais mbappé
dans un instant gilles verdez on en est
ou de cette affaire il ya deux juges
d'instruction qui ont été menées
vendredi et qui avance à grands pas
deux juges nommés vendredi donc avancé
paul pogba a été entendu pour la
deuxième fois mais aujourd'hui on a
appris donc que sa mère aurait été
menacée sans doute par les mêmes hommes
que ceux qui ont à plusieurs reprises
menacé paul pogba et la thèse qui
prévaut même au sein de la famille pogba
aujourd'hui on va vous donner les infos
qu'on a c'est que le frère lorsqu'il a
fait ses vidéos mathias mathias était
peut-être sous influence lui même aurait
été menacée si tu es obligé par des gens
qui veulent récupérer de l'argent auprès
de son frère obligé de parler il lui
aurait dit toi tu vas récupérer l'argent
maintenant mathias qui va récupérer
l'argent a ajouté
[Musique]
le frère aurait été en quelque sorte lui
même racketter et les gens maintenant
relise les vidéos du frère quand on le
voit lire vous savez cyril il lit
beaucoup quand il fait ses vidéos oui
donc il est sans doute c'est la thèse
d'aujourd'hui lui aussi sous influence
c'est toute la famille bourguiba qui
serait menacé par des gens qui
réclameraient 13 millions d'euros pour
la toute première fois un pape est bien
de réagir à la faire ce qui lui mit qui
aurait été la cible d maraboutage un de
paul pogba selon son frère en conférence
de presse pour son match de demain le
joueur du psg a été interrogé sur la
sphère regarder porte à croire qu'au
jour d'aujourd'hui je préfère un
voile à faire confiance à la parole d'un
coéquipier on l'a levé il m'a appelé il
m'a donné sa version des faits
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui au jour d'aujourd'hui à
l'heure où je parle c'est sa parole
contre la parole de son frère donc chez
g je vais faire confiance à mon
coéquipier je pense dans dans l'intérêt
de la sélection aussi je pense qu'on a
une grande compétition et au jour
d'aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est déjà
dans dans certains problèmes je pense
que c'est pas le moment d'en rajouter
pour lui et voilà on va voir comment ça
se passe je suis assez détaché de tout
ça c'est quand même la classe interne
après didier deschamps il est derrière
aussi indiquer quand même
c'est le thonier après didier qui
pensait d'abord à la coupe du monde
puisque didier voilà il veut aller la
chercher la communion je pense que là il
en train de de faire le maximum pour que
l'équipe est s'entendent bien et en plus
paul pogba est blessé et opéré et c'est
très très peu de chance en une fois à la
coupe du monde paul pogba 8 / sur le
marabout en question et sur l'argent qui
aurait versé paul pogba au homard à bout
d'une nouvelle version fin des
développements de la part de paul qui
raconte qui dit que cet argent serait
versée pour une association humanitaire
qui est des enfants d'afrique et qu'il
aurait les moyens de prouver que cet
argent ne serait pas donc pour à des
aides pour faire mal du mal à kilian est
dopée mais pour bien une association
humanitaire
deuxième version parce que c'était
d'abord le marabout pour me protéger les
blessures aujourd'hui c'est le marabout
pour une association c'est vrai que là
il ya quand même encore une grosse
contradiction à ce niveau-là ça c'est un
dossier que les juges d'instruction vont
moins saisir mais qui passionne
l'opinion pellan le la question que tout
le monde nous pose c'est la maman oui
oui vous rendez compte deux frères qui
se déchire c'est toujours
vraiment très très difficile donc la
maman elle en est où la maman elle a été
entendue par les enquêteurs à la
raconter ça ils prennent ça très au
sérieux il faut savoir que lorsque la
raconter quoi elle a raconté qu'elle a
été menacée par des hommes armés qui ont
toquer à sa porte aux qualités
relationnelles a été menacé en juillet
c'est ce qu'elle raconte elle a ouvert l
a vu ses hommes et elle a été tellement
apeuré qu'elle à fait légitimement appel
à l'intendant de l'équipe de france qui
protège les joueurs qui les entourent
qui est un homme très précieux pour
l'équipe de france très proche de didier
deschamps et qu'elle a demandé à cet
homme-là de la protéger ça montre à quel
point elle a peur elle aussi et c'est
vrai que les juges ont l'impression
qu'il ya un vrai racket depuis très
longtemps organisé autour de paul pogba
d'accord ça touche également d'autres
joueurs ont pas dû pour le moment non ça
touche paul pogba sans doute depuis ses
débuts au havre il ya très longtemps
toute sa carrière professionnelle va
être lu par les juges c'est aussi pour
ça qu'ils sont deux pour voir s'il y
avait des mouvements d'argent du racket
autour de lui depuis ses débuts
professionnels jusqu à manchester où il
ya eu la phase aiguë où il a décidé de
se débarrasser de gens de son entourage
donc ça faisait des années pour des
années sans donne il se dira qui dit des
années sans doute c'est ce que les juges
tente de démêler c'est une possibilité
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il aurait quitté
manchester pour tuera alors quand il
aurait vu qu'à turin ça ce que racontait
géré à vis de l'autre jour il a quand
même été menacé au bord du centre
d'entraînement de turin là il s'est dit
ou que j'aille je serai menacé et il a
porté plainte à ce moment là quand c'est
pas parce que je change de pays que je
suis débarrassé de ces gens là oui mais
si ça s'est confirmé que pogba est
vraiment racketter je pense que ça il va
servir de lanceurs d'alertés entre il ya
beaucoup d'autres joueurs français qui
vont parler mais qui vont dire que eux
mêmes subi des raquettes depuis leur
plus jeune âge centre de formation et
compagnie parle aussi de racket sur les
stars de télé-réalité
oui c'est vrai que quand on dit beaucoup
que autour des gens si on dit que si on
a beaucoup qui partent à dubaï pour ça
voilà alors autour des gens de la nuit
ou autour des footballeurs quand ils
viennent et qui parfois sorte et qui ont
autour d'eux des gens qu'ils connaissent
depuis leur enfance qui parfois sont
certains milieux on dit qu'il ya des
gens qui profitent de leur notoriété
pour les racketter c'est vrai on dit on
dit qu'il ya eu des joueurs de foot
racketter mais on n'a pas les noms on
dit que des stars de télé-réalité
effectivement parfois s'enfuit parce
qu'il ya un racket autour d'eux il ya
deux choses
les produits stupéfiants parfois vous
prenez de la drogue une fois et après on
vous dit on a des photos on t'a vu on a
des témoins et deuxième chose possible
star de la prostitution c'est à dire que
des gens à qui entre guillemets on
donne la possibilité d'approcher une
jeune femme après ils sont rackettés et
on leur dit si tu ne payes pas les
dossiers vont sortir donc oui oui ou non
ces des personnalités qui sont souvent
issus de milieux défavorisés qui
réussissent de manière très rapide qui
gagne énormément d'argent et souvent ça
suscite des jalousies et ces personnes
là qui partent à dubaï notamment vous
l'avez dit dise voilà en france on est
jaloux donc quand il elle exhibe tout ce
qu'ils ont sur les réseaux sociaux
souvent elles sont victimes de
cambriolages elles n'ont qu'elle parte à
dubaï en disant voilà au moins ici on
est sûr et c'est que ça arrive très
régulièrement france des cambriolages
des raquettes et du vol malheureusement
d'accord c'est avec l'appui de huit
enfin pendant je pars sur autre chose
mais certains assurent maintenant ne
vont plus assurer les gens qui postent
des photos sur instagram par les oignons
pourquoi oui ça parce que la police m'a
dit maman vous partez vous pas papa donc
prenez un gars célibataire je serais
rien à gagner moi je suis batteur vous
partez en vacances et les barbes et vous
poster des photos de vacances c'est ce
que m'a dit la police autant donner
directement vos clés aux cambrioleurs
savent que vous n'êtes pas là et
certains assureurs aujourd'hui dit si
vous postez vos photos de vacances sur
instagram que vous donnez justement ce
genre d'information est bien n'assurera
plus en k2 en cas de
doute quand ils s'en moquent souvent ils
sont cons brio l'histoire
et vous madame de fontenay qui tous les
soirs d'élection était que visiter
régulièrement l'avortement
ça se saurait c'est pour ça que 3 et
toulouse ce week end